Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man video the
original writer of the movie came out
and just explained what his original
super dark ending for the movie was
going to be a bunch of deleted scenes in
an alternate storyline for that first
trilogy as well as what the story
through spider-man 6 was going to be
that's right they were originally
planning six different spider-man movies
so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your predictions for
spider-man 3 on the video so because
there's a lot of alternate story and
deleted scenes here all just number two
these differently as we go along but
this goes all the way back to Sam Raimi
and Tobey Maguire's spider-man
so the original writer of that first
spider-man movie David Koepp was doing
an interview for a couple other movies
in during that he talked about the
original plans for those first
spider-man trilogy that he had mapped
out and it was going to be way more Empire
Strikes Back in his own words way darker
way different villain layout then when I
initially talked about them doing six
movies with Tobey Maguire's spider-man
he was actually going to come back later
and do three more movies for Sony before
things changed again so I'll explain all
those but originally during the first
movie one of the biggest changes would
have been they would have started with
gwen stacy in the green goblin saga from
the comics where there was no Mary Jane
yet in Peter Parker's first relationship
after he became spider-man and got the
spider bite was with gwen stacy just
like it was in the comics then at the
end of the first movie it would have
been gwen stacy that the green goblin
throws off the bridge like he does at
the end of the theatrical cut with Mary
Jane and her neck would have been
snapped when spider-man tries to catch
her just like it happened in the comics
a much much darker ending to that first
movie originally Stan Lee explained that
the reason why they killed off gwen
stacy this way is because they felt like
mary jane was a more complex character
and they wanted to introduce her to the
forefront so in order to do that they
felt like the best solution was to kill
off the gwen stacy character eventually
the studio did do a version of this
story line during amazing spider-man 2
with Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone but
in the original version of events with
Tobey Maguire spider-man that would have
led to spider-man 2 starting off in a
much darker place like he mentions
Empire Strikes Back in terms of the
trilogy for Spider
man has been way more shaken up after a
Gwen Stacy's death but he's just
starting to develop a relationship with
Mary Jane
then the villains that he fought in the
subsequent spider-man movies would have
still been coerced sinister six villains
but the order of the villains and which
members of the sinister six that he
fought at each different time would have
been a little bit different like in
spider-man 2
he faces Doctor Octopus in the
theatrical cut with a little development
on the Harry Osborn Green Goblin arc but
originally Sony had actually planned to
do way way more villains this is
starting to sound familiar so it would
have been Doctor Octopus the lizard
black cat and even more Harry Osborn
Green Goblin then was originally in the
movie instead of calling it spider-man 2
they would have called it the amazing
spider-man and Doctor Octopus was going
to be very different he was going to be a
much younger version of the character he
was going to be revealed as the person
who created the genetically altered
spider that gave spider-man his powers
he would have also been in a love
triangle with Mary Jane and Peter Parker
his spine still becomes fused to the
tentacle harness like it did in the
theatrical cut but it starts to kill him
slowly and he would have tried to take
spider-man's spine to replace his so you
can see how much darker they had planned
to take the spider-man movies then a
much more comic-book accurate version of
the Harry Osborn Green Goblin would have
teamed up with him to fight spider-man
and take out a ten million dollar bounty
on his head in The Daily Bugle with Jay
jonah Jameson it was actually Sam Raimi
that revealed that he'd changed the
Doctor Octopus storyline for the
theatrical cut it was his idea to make
him Peter Parker's hero as a scientist
before he becomes Doctor Octopus he
wanted the big final battle to be more
about Peter trying to save him from his
demons rather than just trying to kill
him they kind of replicated that
relationship for the spider-man ps4 game
with Peter Parker being one of doctor
octopus's students at Empire State
University in the tragic villain turned
during the movie and then the big final
battle was also kind of similar to then
by the time we get to spider-man 3
originally in the alternate storyline it
would have led to a more climactic
sinister six style team up with a bigger
more comic-book accurate version of the
Harry Osborn Green Goblin they were
always going to do Sandman because Sam
Raimi just really obsessed with the
Sandman character and originally before
they decided on including the venom
character they were going to do the vulture
and he
would have been played by get it Ben
Kingsley later we all saw Ben Kingsley
showed up in the Marvel movies as the
fake Trevor version of the Mandarin he
also came back in the Marvel one-shot
from Iron Man 3 called all hail the king
just as a way for Marvel to tease the
real Mandarin which we're all actually
going to see next year in a Marvel phase
4 movie Shang Chi and The Legend of the ten
rings that's going to be Marvel's Big
Spring movie next year they were always
planning on doing a version of the venom
storyline but originally it was very
different and merely just spider-man
getting the symbiote this is when they
were still planning on doing four to six
spider-man movies with Tobey Maguire so
presumably their intent with spider-man
4 would have been to introduce a version
of Eddie Brock then give him the
symbiote during that the theatrical cut
of spider-man 3 combines a couple
different venom stories from the
symbiote saga spider-man gets the
symbiote during Secret Wars then learns
about it during subsequent amazing
spider-man stories then way down the
line they do the famous church scene
where he gets rid of it and then
separately in another story when they
started doing the venom solo title they
reckoned that a little bit instead that
Eddie Brock had been there at the church
when that was happening and that's how
he got the symbiote and became comic
book venom so spider-man 3 just sort of
crammed a ton of different Venom
symbiote stories into that one movie
then when they were still planning on
doing 4 to 6 Tobey Maguire spider-man
movies they would have also done Venom's
spin-offs that's where you get to toxin
a lot of the other crazier versions of
the symbiotes like carnage Sam Raimi
then said right after they finished
spider-man 3 that was one that talks
about Sony doing back-to-back shoots for
spider-man 4 and spider-man 5 were
happening with Tobey Maguire in the
exact same production team that's right
they were initially planning on doing an
Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgames situation with Tobey Maguire's
spider-man and that's also when they
hired the screenwriter to plot out
through spider-man 6 with Tobey Maguire
just to give you an idea for how far out
they were thinking about his story it
would have slowly turned him into what
Ironman became in the MCU or even like
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine somebody who
played the character for way more than
10 years when Sam Raimi was talking
about spider-man 4 in spider-man 5 he
was making a lot of comparisons to Peter
Jackson doing the Lord of the Rings
trilogy because he filmed all those
movies back-to-back the story for
spider-man 4 at that point
was them going back to the vulture
character as the main villain he would
have been a very different version from
the comics he would have been played by
John Malkovich he would have been
revealed is a relative of Mary Jane's
taking control of the Daily Bugle from
Jay jonah Jameson they were going to
introduce a version of Anne Hathaway as
Felicia Hardy who instead of becoming
the black cat would have actually become
a female version of the vulture the
reason why they said they did that
instead of doing black cat is because
they felt like she would have become too
much of a copy of the Catwoman character
which is hilarious because Anne Hathaway
would then go on just a little while
after that to be Catwoman they would
have finally gone full lizard with Curt
Connors from the previous movies and
then they would have revealed bruce
campbell as a version of the Quentin
Beck Mysterio
there are even story boards for a lot of
this - I don't know how they would have
explained the previous versions of bruce
campbell that had cameo scenes in the
other spider-man movies but the reason
why spider-man for spider-man 5 and
spider-man 6 fell apart and why Sony
decided to reboot the character was
mostly because Sam Raimi said that he
felt creatively exhausted and didn't
think that they could make the planned
release date for spider-man 4 that Sony
had said so he backed out of the project
and that's when the house of cards
started to fold Tobey Maguire then
backed out and that was pretty much it
in Walsh Sony was planning spider-man 4
5 & 6 with the new rider in the new team
separately they were also hedging their
bets with a reboot in a recast of
spider-man that's why they were so quick
to announce Andrew Garfield's amazing
spider-man right after Sam Raimi and
Tobey Maguire left the project it had
already been in the works for a long
time that's just the way the studio's
operate they always have contingency
plans in case directors back out actors
back out
that's how Marvel was able to announce
Sam Raimi as the new director of Doctor
Strange to multiverse of madness so
quickly after scott derrickson backed
out earlier this year let me know in the
comments though what do you think about
the alternate darker spider-man
storyline the darker version of the
Venom symbiote saga and the alternate
plans for what Tobey Maguire spider-man
would have been you have to keep in mind
though if they hadn't made it through
all 6 of those spider-man films that
would have taken them up into modern day
MCU through Civil War and it would have
been Tobey Maguire spider-man crossing
over with the Avengers instead of Tom
Hollands spider-man there was even a
deleted scene from that first Ironman
post-credit scene where Nick
Puri references spider-man that was
going to be Toby's spider-man for those
of you that really want to see him come
back in a cameo scene at some point Lord
and Miller revealed that they tried to
bring back both Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield with Tom Holland for cameos in
the first spider-man into the
spider-verse movie but they claimed that
Sony shot them down on the grounds that
they felt like it was too soon to do
something like that spider-man into the
spider verse two is coming out in 2022
hopefully by then they'll say yes and
bring them back but there's also talk of
doing a live-action spider-man into the
spider verse in the fact that Sam Raimi
is making new Marvel movies again I am
sure at some point we'll see some
classic Tobey Maguire spider-man Easter
eggs and maybe even a cameo scene at
some point there's also the easter egg
from the Morbius trailer with the
spider-man wall mural it's actually
Tobey Maguire's costume but it's from a
spider-man game and it's referencing the
Tom Hollands spider-man from the end of
spider-man far from home
there's also bus advertisements for
spider-man in the Daily Bugle in its
Tobey Maguire's version of The Daily
Bugle so there is a lot of Tobey Easter
eggs in the Morbius movie right now but
that could be a misdirect
they'll be filming Tom Hollands Marvel's
spider-man 3 later this year so there'll
be some news about that coming up I'll
do videos for everything leave all your
requests in the comments below
congratulations Jack Frost you're the
giveaway winner for my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my venom 2
trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for my new spider-man PS5 trailer
with Miles Morales thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see
you guys tonight!